cartable sur le dos vélo à la main
retrouvailles entre copines pas de doute
comme partout en france
au groupe scolaire du bois de la garenne
aujourd'hui c'est la rentrée lire encore
l'établissement vie sinois étaient
pratiquement vides seules activités
les derniers préparatifs avant le jour j
caroline guignard à 28 ans elle est
professeure stagiaire et pour la
première fois elle va se retrouver
devant une classe de 25 élèves de
maternelle âgée de quatre à cinq ans
pour le premier jour des bout'choux elle
n'a laissé aucun détail au hasard un
moment d'accueil autour de jeux divers
dans la classe ensuite un moment de
regroupement où on va se présenter
chacun notre tour à la fois les élèves
qui se connaissent déjà mais également
les nouveaux et moi même bien sûr
puisque moi je vais te la nouvelle
maîtresse ici pour devenir stagiaire
caroline a suivi un master de professeur
des écoles à l'université versailles
saint quentin
elle a bénéficié d'un dispositif en
alternance grâce auquel elle a eu en
charge tous les lundis une classe de ce2
pendant un an
malgré cela elle estime avoir encore
beaucoup à apprendre sur le niveau
maternelle
une demi heure avant l'arrivée des
élèves caroline est confiante je suis
arrivé à 7h30
en arrivant j'ai disposé les étiquettes
sur les portemanteaux j'ai préparé les
différents jeux pour l'accueil sur les
tables et dans les différents coins de
la classe une préparation qui semble
avoir plu aux enfants un dernier coup
mes parents et c'est parti pour une
année qui s'annonce riche en nouvelles
expériences pour tout le monde